Traduttore: Roberto Minelli
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Fin da quando ero piccolo,
sono sempre stato -
ho sempre apprezzato la bellezza
che si può osservare in natura.
E, in particolare,
sono sempre stato affascinato
dalle forme e dai colori
che si possono osservare
attraverso gli insetti,
in particolare i coleotteri.
Io sono di Como
e passavo tutte le mie estati
a cercare di prendere
questi cervi volanti, quelli in mezzo,
che erano fantastici quando volano -
e ce ne sono sempre di meno, qua intorno.
E sono finito a lavorare in California
con un altro insetto,
uno che senz'altro
voi adorate, anche: la zanzara.
Quello delle zanzare è un problema enorme,
perché ogni anno causano
quasi un milione di morti sulla Terra:
tra tutti gli animali sono i più mortali
e ci lasciano al secondo posto
nella classifica dei ‘killer’.
Le zanzare di per sé sono innocue,
ci danno [fastidio], sono
fastidiose, però sono innocue.
Il problema è che sono vettori
di parassiti e virus
che causano malattie molto debilitanti
e in molti casi anche mortali.
La peggiore di queste malattie,
al momento, è la malaria.
La malaria è causata da un parassita
che si chiama Plasmodium.
E queste zanzare non sono nate
con il Plasmodium:
devono pungere qualcuno che è infettato
per poi trasmetterlo
a una persona non infetta.
Ed è così che la malaria
si trasmette da una persona all'altra.
Questo Plasmodium
è un parassita intracellulare:
una volta che è entrato
nel nostro flusso sanguigno,
entra nei nostri globuli rossi,
si riproduce all'interno
e se li mangia uno alla volta,
ed questo che causa la malaria.
È portata da zanzare, come abbiamo detto,
ma non tutte le zanzare
possono portare il Plasmodium.
Per esempio, la zanzara tigre,
che senz'altro avete sentito,
non può portare la malaria.
Solamente un piccolo gruppo
di zanzare anopheles,
del genus anopheles,
possono portare la malaria.
In più, questo Plasmodium
è specifico per gli uomini:
questo vuol dire
che non può essere trasmesso
dagli animali o agli animali.
In più, non può sopravvivere
in una palude, in una foresta.
È un parassita obbligato:
vuol dire che rimane all'interno
dell'uomo e della zanzara.
E questo ci dà un vantaggio
perché potremmo, in teoria,
rompere completamente questo ciclo
e il suo ciclo di vita,
che è completato completamente
dentro la zanzara e l'uomo.
Con medicine e pesticidi
potremmo rompere il ciclo,
e se potessimo farlo istantaneamente
su tutta la faccia della Terra
potremmo debellare la malattia.
Il problema è che non è così facile
applicare queste medicine
e pesticidi ovunque,
e la malaria rimane endemica
in un sacco di Paesi,
specialmente i Paesi più poveri.
Ed è ancora un enorme problema
specialmente in Africa,
nel centro-sud Africa,
dove causa la morte
di migliaia di bambini –
le persone più afflitte
sono i bambini sotto i 5 anni.
Il Plasmodium si è evoluto
con gli uomini,
quindi è stato con noi da millenni.
E negli ultimi 150 anni
abbiamo iniziato a combattere
le zanzare e il Plasmodium
con tutti i mezzi
che riuscivamo a trovare:
abbiamo usato zanzariere
per bloccare le zanzare;
abbiamo usato pesticidi
e li abbiamo messi sulle zanzariere
per cercare di ucciderle;
abbiamo fumigato intere città
con questi pesticidi
cercando di uccidere le zanzare.
E in più abbiamo sviluppato medicine,
sia per prevenire il Plasmodium –
che sto anche prendendo io,
perché sono stato
in India settimana scorsa –
oppure per curare persone
che fossero infette dal Plasmodium.
Tutti questi metodi
stanno lentamente fallendo,
dal momento che li abbiamo usati
per così tanto tempo.
E molti esperti
nel campo medico-scientifico
stanno – sono molto preoccupati
perché, per esempio, le zanzare
stanno sviluppando un nuovo comportamento
e hanno imparato a pungerci
alla sera fuori dalla casa,
invece che dentro mentre stiamo dormendo.
In più, hanno sviluppato
resistenza ai pesticidi
e, alla stessa maniera,
il Plasmodium ha anche sviluppato
resistenza alle medicine che usiamo.
E questo è anche rispecchiato
nell’aumento di casi di malaria
che si può osservare
negli ultimi due o tre anni.
Ora, non sono stato invitato
qua da Gerolamo
perché sono un esperto di malaria,
ma perché sono esperto
di ingegneria genetica.
E prima di parlarvi del nuovo strumento
che stiamo sviluppando in California
[che] usa la genetica
per combattere la malaria,
faccio un piccolo rinfresco
di genetica di base.
Le zanzare, esattamente come noi,
hanno due copie del genoma:
uno che viene dalla mamma
e uno che viene dal papà.
E se prendiamo una zanzara
che è blu perché ha un gene blu,
diciamo che venga dalla mamma
questo gene blu,
questo gene blu –
una volta che la zanzara blu
si accoppia con una zanzara nera –
ha il 50% delle probabilità
di dare questo gene blu alla sua progenie,
quindi solamente la metà
dei figli di questa zanzara
saranno anche loro blu.
E, generazione dopo generazione,
questo gene blu rimane nella popolazione
con una certa frequenza,
seguendo le leggi dell'eredità di Mendel.
Mentre io stavo lavorando
sul mio dottorato, a San Diego,
mi sono chiesto:
“E se avessimo un gene verde
che invece potrebbe, in qualche modo,
convertire quel gene nero
che viene dall'altro genitore
ad essere anche lui verde,
com'è che questa eredità
di Mendel sarebbe modificata?”.
La zanzara verde, ora,
ha due copie di questo gene
e, se si accoppia con una zanzara nera,
non ha il 50% di probabilità
di darlo ai figli,
ma tutti i suoi figli avranno
una copia di questo gene verde;
in più, dal momento
che ha questa capacità di copiarsi
sull'altra copia del genoma
che viene dall'altro genitore,
generazione dopo generazione
la frequenza di questo gene verde
aumenterà nella popolazione,
fino a che l'intera popolazione
non avrà questo gene verde.
Questo tipo di eredità
è stato studiato da quasi cent'anni:
si chiama “gene drive”
ed occorre in natura,
quindi ci sono diversi meccanismi
che possono generare un'eredità aumentata,
tipo questa che stiamo cercando di fare.
In California, quello
che noi abbiamo fatto
è generare un gene drive
che è completamente sintetico,
quindi completamente fatto in laboratorio,
che può essere usato per modificare -
per essere inserito in qualsiasi punto
nel genoma della zanzara.
[Ci siamo riusciti]
usando una nuova tecnologia
che è stata sviluppata recentemente,
che si chiama “CRISPR”,
e i due componenti base
della tecnologia “CRISPR”
si chiamano “Cas9” e “Guide RNA”.
La “Cas9” è come se fosse -
è un enzima, ed è come se fosse
una forbice molecolare
fatta per tagliare il DNA;
mentre il “Guide RNA”
è come se fosse un indirizzo:
dice esattamente
alla “Cas9” dove tagliare.
Abbiamo preso un gene per la “Cas9”
e un gene per il “Guide RNA”
e l'abbiamo messo in mezzo
a una sequenza di DNA
che è esattamente uguale
a quella del genoma di una zanzara.
Questo pezzo di DNA sintetico, circolare,
che si chiama Plasmide,
è stato iniettato
dentro le uova delle zanzare
e funziona in questa maniera:
la “Cas9” e il “Guide RNA” si uniscono,
il “Guide RNA” dice esattamente
alla “Cas9” dove tagliare
e tagliano il genoma
ad una certa posizione.
A questo punto, la cellula
non può sopravvivere col DNA rotto,
e quindi si guarda in giro,
trova una sequenza che è uguale
e la usa come [modello]
per correggere quel taglio;
e quindi, in questa maniera,
riusciamo a inserire
la “Cas9” e il “Guide RNA”
esattamente a quella posizione.
È così che abbiamo creato
la prima zanzara transgenica
con questo metodo.
Cosa succede subito dopo?
L'altra copia del genoma,
quella che è il gene nero,
con la stessa maniera
adesso viene tagliata
sempre dalla “Cas9” e dal “Guide RNA”,
che adesso sono dentro
nel genoma della zanzara,
e viene copiata nella
stessa identica posizione
sull'altra copia del cromosoma,
esattamente quel gene verde
che volevamo fare.
Ora, voi direte –
non è che vogliamo fare
zanzare verdi o le zanzare blu:
gli vogliamo dare una caratteristica
che possa aiutarci
nella lotta contro le zanzare.
E per questo io
e il mio mentore Ethan Bier,
che stavamo lavorando
su questo “gene drive”,
ci siamo messi in collaborazione
con un altro professore
dell'Università della
California di Irvine,
che invece aveva sviluppato
una seconda cassetta genetica
che rende le zanzare immuni
al Plasmodium della malaria.
Queste zanzare di Tony,
una volta che pungono
qualcuno che ha il Plasmodium,
non possono trasmetterlo
a una persona non infetta.
Com'è che funzionano queste zanzare
che questo ricercatore ha generato?
Quando le zanzare si fanno
una bella bevuta di sangue,
e si mangiano anche
i plasmodi nel frattempo,
questi plasmodi devono
uscire dallo stomaco
e entrare nel sistema
linfatico della zanzara.
Queste zanzare sono però modificate,
così che producano degli anticorpi –
tra l'altro sono anticorpi umani,
quindi c'è una cassetta
genetica, nella zanzara,
che produce anticorpi umani –
che bloccano i Plasmodi,
mentre stanno cercando
di uscire dallo stomaco.
Se anche uno di questi plasmodi
riesce a uscire nel sistema linfatico,
c’è un secondo anticorpo
che è lì pronto con una tossina
per ucciderlo prima che riesca
ad arrivare alle ghiandole salivari,
dove deve arrivare per essere trasmesso
alla prossima persona.
Quello che abbiamo fatto è:
abbiamo combinato
il nostro “gene drive” sintetico
con questa nuova caratteristica,
e abbiamo creato queste zanzare.
Queste zanzare hanno, in teoria,
la capacità di modificare
l'intera popolazione del mondo
delle zanzare anopheles
ad essere completamente
immuni alla malaria.
E, nel giro di un anno,
potrebbero debellare
la malaria completamente.
Ora, come abbiamo detto prima,
la realtà è sempre un po' diversa,
e quindi fare un'applicazione del genere
in tutto il mondo è molto complesso,
la genetica delle zanzare è complessa
e anche quella dei parassiti
è molto complessa.
Quindi, questa tecnologia
andrà a supplementare
l'uso di pesticidi, medicine e vaccini
che sono in sviluppo.
Alcuni di voi si saranno chiesti,
come anche altre persone:
“Ma non è pericoloso
modificare un'intera specie?”,
“Non è che può avere
delle implicazioni sull'ecosistema
che non sono previste?”
Queste sono senz'altro delle domande
che ci dobbiamo chiedere,
quando facciamo l'applicazione
di una tecnologia così potente.
Ma vorrei mettere le cose
un pochino in prospettiva
e comparare questo “gene drive”
a quello che stiamo usando a tutt’oggi
per combattere gli insetti.
L’unico sistema
è un sistema molto complesso,
ci sono molti nodi.
E al momento rovesciamo tonnellate
e tonnellate di pesticidi nell’ecosistema
cercando di uccidere questi insetti.
Le zanzare sono uno di quelli,
altri sono pesti di agricoltura
o anche, non so, le formiche
che ti entrano in casa,
ti danno fastidio e le vuoi uccidere.
E facendo così,
non vai a colpire solamente
l'insetto che non ti piace:
vai a colpire tutti gli insetti
di un intero ecosistema,
e in più hai un effetto indiretto
su piante e animali che hanno
delle relazioni con questi insetti,
per esempio animali
che si mangiano gli insetti.
Un “gene drive”
non ha un effetto del genere:
un “gene drive” è una cosa
che è squisitamente specifica
per una sola specie,
quindi un solo anello
all'interno di un ecosistema.
E in più non è che lo rimuoviamo:
gli diamo semplicemente
una caratteristica leggermente diversa,
così che non possa portare
il parassita che ci [dà fastidio].
Con il riscaldamento climatico
e la globalizzazione,
questi insetti si stanno muovendo
di continente in continente,
e ogni anno stanno sempre
venendo più a nord,
portandosi con loro anche queste malattie.
La malaria in Italia è una cosa
che accade molto sporadicamente,
ma senz'altro avete sentito della paura
che ci siamo presi con la Zika
un paio d'anni fa,
e altre malattie
come la dengue e la chikungunya
stanno diventando un serio problema
in tutto il mondo.
Quindi io sono convinto
che questo “gene drive”
sia un nuovo strumento
a nostra disposizione,
che potremo usare
per una lotta sostenibile
contro queste malattie.
Grazie.
(Applausi)